et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
eric ciotti bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous des percées
républicain des alpes-maritimes et on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
patrice maggio que vous connaissez bien
eric ciotti c'est le directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de nice-matin bonjour
matrix merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
on commence évidemment par la crise
sanitaire avec ce type plusieurs
vaccinant groupes qui ont donc été lancé
hier au havre à roubaix à nantes et au
stade de france où jean castex est rendu
tout un symbole c'est ce qu'il a dit au
stade de france est ce que vous dites ça
y est la campagne de vaccination elle
est enfin bel et bien lancée elle est
lancée avec malheureusement beaucoup de
retard puisque les chiffres et les
comparaisons internationales sont
importantes à regarder on mesure que la
france et l'europe accumule toutes les
deux l'union européenne et en son sein
la france accumule des retards très
importants
les comparaisons sont même cruel si on
compare avec nos amis britanniques près
de 50 % des britanniques sont
aujourd'hui vacciner nous sommes un peu
+ 13 % pour la france de français ayant
reçu une dose les israéliens c'est 60%
les états unis c'est 30 % donc on a
malheureusement a cumulé deux à trois
mois de retard au début de la campagne
aujourd'hui ça s'accélère mais je note
que le lundi de pâques
il y a eu à peine 70 milles vaccination
ça reste un rythme qui est faible et qui
est trop faible par rapport à la
recherche de l'immunité collective
qu'apportera le vaccin et j'ai lu hier
l'étude de l'institut pasteur qui
souligne que tant que les jeunes
n'auront pas été vaccinés notamment les
enfants et bien on ne sortira pas aussi
de l'epide est alors justement est ce
que pour vous il faut changer de
stratégie vaccinale aujourd'hui encore
sur une catégorisation par âge est ce
que vous dites c'est pas la bonne
stratégie il faut ouvrir la vaccination
plus largement ou pas je suis pas
médecin ni scientifique
j'ai vu que des politiques pays cités
ils n'ont pas la même stratégie sénat
j'ai vu que des politiques s'ériger en
médecins que le président de la
république selon ses proches ou ses
courtisans se baigner parer des vertus
d'un immunologiste voir doté selon le
président de l'assemblée nationale de
l'agrégation de médecine
bon je n'ai pas ses compétences donc
j'ai pas de réponse mais je regarde un
effet ce qui se passe ailleurs et en
tout cas je pense que toute la
population
ceux qui le souhaitent naturellement
doit être vacciné nous avons aussi des
publics prioritaires
je pense aux enseignants on accumule en
retard très important la matière le
ministre de l'éducation évoqué en
janvier une vaccination de tous les
enseignants mi mars
on est désormais au mieux sur le
commencement de cette vaccination
mi-avril donc on a accumulé en matière
de vaccination un retard dramatique et
on a accumulé du fait de la mauvaise
stratégie européenne qui paye finalement
son carcan technocratique et
bureaucratiques
les doses de vaccins ont été négociés
par des bureaucrates européens qui n'ont
regardé que le critère budgétaire et
alors il fallait pas passer par l'union
européenne je ne crois pas qu'il fallait
mettre tous les oeufs dans le même
panier
je pense qu'il y avait une commande de
européenne pourquoi pas mais qu'elle
nous nous exonérer pas d'avoir nous même
notre propre stratégie
d'autant qu'on a mesurée très vite que
la stratégie européenne était
défaillante
patrice maggio péril ce rythme est
clairement devant le devant le vaccin
est ce qu'on vaccine correctement dans
l'arrière-pays niçois je pense notamment
aux vallées sinistrées de la roya et de
la vésubie
oui dans le département des alpes
maritimes
on a un taux de vaccination qui
aujourd'hui et est supérieure à la
moyenne nationale vous citez dans nice
matin
ce matin les chiffres le département des
alpes-maritimes compte à peu près deux
cent dix mille personnes maxi
et c'est pas loin de 20 % de la
population
on est à 14 % au plan national donc on
est un département qui a subi un choc
épidémique violents depuis le mois de
février
cela a conduit à des mesures de
restriction importante donc nous avions
demandé tous les élus avaient demandé
qu'on bénéficie de doses de vaccins
supplémentaires
cette accélération elle a eu lieu et
elle est répartie sous le contrôle des
préfets du préfet de façon équitable sur
tout le territoire et c'est le
département des alpes-maritimes qui a
notamment la responsabilité des zones
qui ont subi la tempête alex la vallée
de la roya notamment mais aussi dans la
vallée de la vésubie et cette
vaccination se déroule parfaitement bien
c'est le cas notamment sur tout le pays
dont le département a la responsabilité
les agglomérations à la métropole ayant
la responsabilité de la zone littorale
sur la situation sanitaire dans le
département des alpes-maritimes ça fait
plusieurs semaines maintenant vous êtes
soumis à des mesures restrictives
est ce qu'elles ont porté leurs fruits
ces mesures la structure les chiffres
s'améliorent
il faut rester extrêmement prudent mais
le taux d'incidence a diminué il est
aujourd'hui légèrement supérieure à 400
cas pour 100000 habitants nous étions
montés jusqu'à 680 hier soir le nombre
de personnes admises en réanimation qui
reste très élevé a légèrement diminué
c'est également le cas sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations donc ça veut dire que
le gouvernement ait eu raison de prendre
ces mesures
il fallait moi j'ai toujours prôné
l'anticipation et des mesures prises
très tôt et j'ai souhaité et je pense
que c'est une erreur majeure que ces
mesures soient prises au niveau national
dès le 29 janvier vous rappelez quand
tout le monde annonce est une forme de
restriction
et puis que le président de la
république a surpris est allé à
l'encontre des avis du conseil
scientifique de l'avis des médecins
[Musique]
il faut les suivre à la lettre la
décision à un moment elle est politique
bien sûr parce qu'elle dépasse le cadre
scientifique mais quand vous avez toutes
les modélisations de l'inserm de
l'institut pasteur qui compte tenu de
l'arrivée des variants nous prédisait et
prévoyez un pic épidémique à partir de
mars quand vous avez le conseil
scientifique qui a été créée autour du
président de la république qui émet un
avis un avis qu'on allait laisser dans
le secret pendant deux à trois semaines
quand vous avez tous les médecins qui
lance un cri d'alarmé
je crois qu'il est de la responsabilité
du pouvoir politique oui de l'écouté moi
je dis que le président de la république
a commis une faute lourde dans son choix
du 29 janvier qui nous a fait perdre du
temps j'entends il a encore dit hier
dans son intervention devant les
collégiens que nous avions gagné du
temps gagné du temps sur les contraintes
moi je vois ce qui se passe ailleurs
encore une fois le deal à la vie va
reprendre en grande bretagne a déjà
repris en espagne et nous nous y sommes
encore pour plusieurs semaines parce que
nous allons vers le pic épidémique dont
c'est du temps que nous avons perdu
c'est de l'argent il fallait vous
confiné cd vite nous allons perdre et je
pense que les pays qui ont réussi ont
confiné ont vacciné de façon ponctuelle
façon territorialisée de façon
anticipative c'est cette anticipation
qui a toujours fait défaut
ça fait maintenant plus d'un an que
cette crise a commencé
et chaque fois on a eu un temps de
retard mais on entend les difficultés
des commerçants on entend les
difficultés à l'école est ce que pour
vous il n'a pas eu raison finalement
de laisser le pays ouvert est ce qu'on
pouvait prendre le risque entre
guillemets de confiner dès le 29 janvier
oui parce qu'on en serait sorti
aujourd'hui et c'était le risque et
c'était un pari j'aime pas ce mot parce
qu'on a parié quelque part sur des vies
humaines et c'était un mauvais choix
c'était une erreur et nous en payons
lourdement le prix aujourd'hui
le restaurateur ou encore certains vont
jusqu'à ouvrir de restauration des
restaurants qu'un destin les hommes
restent autant d'eau vous avez bien sûr
suivi la polémique autour de la fameuse
réception de l'hôtel visuel est ce que
vous vous cette année déjeuner dans un
de ses restaurants ne serait ce que pour
prendre la mesure du phénomène
non absolument pas naturellement
d'ailleurs je n'en connais pas on a eu
dans notre ville de nice je crois moment
des fêtes
un restaurant qui a été sanctionné pour
pour cela non je n'y suis naturellement
pas pas aller je condamne bien entendu
ces attitudes il ya une règle qui
participe de la sécurité collective et
il est impératif bien entendu de la
respecter et dernière question puisqu'on
parle de restauration dernière question
sur ce sujet patrice forcément prévu ce
qui est sûr c'est maintenant avec le
calendrier qu'on retrouve un
gouvernement fait la saison ont fêté qui
est en jeu et vous puis le restaurant
points commencent à s'inquiéter
est ce que vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux
attendre quitte à perdre une seconde
activité
mais pour certains sur le plan sanitaire
l'épidémie survécu quitte à sacrifier
une ou deux secondes de l'activité moi
je sincèrement je le crois on peut pas
continuer à avoir c'est stop and go ou
en faire mon réouvre et aux encres et de
la fragilité
je crois qu'il faut arriver à ce que le
virus disparaisse il faut stopper la
circulation
du virus regardons là encore on
n'invente pas l'eau tiède mais ce qui se
fait en corée du sud en nouvelle zélande
en australie
c'est la stratégie zéro co vide donc il
faut éradiquer le plus possible la
circulation du virus est parallèlement
accélérer très fortement la vaccination
donc tant qu'on annonce on aura passé
deux éléments qui se rejoignent on n'en
sortira pas donc il faut sur les deux
points accélère on va passer au reste de
l'actualité avec ce tee et notamment
l'actualité à l'assemblée nationale et
ce texte sur la fin de vie qui sera
examiné jeudi avec plus de deux mille
amendements déposés par certains députés
des républicains ce qui va conduire à
priori à l'impossibilité d'examiner
correctement ce texte et de l'adopter
dans le temps imparti
est-ce que vous assumez cette
obstruction parlementaire est ce que les
républicains il ne s'abîme pas en
empêchant de débattre sur un tel sujet
il y a aucun amendement du groupe l'est
républicain le droit d'amendement est
une liberté constitutionnelle et c'est
heureux de chaque parlementaire donc il
y à des parlementaires
et il y en a qui font partie de mon
groupe il y en a d'autres qui ont déposé
des amendements pour s'opposer à ce
texte ne pose plus de 2000 âmes et
d'obstruction
c'est leur droit constitutionnel après
quel est le fond ou la forme de ce débat
est un problème de forme et de fond
au nez dans ce qu'on appelle la niche
parlementaire vous le savez donc c'est à
peine une journée de débats où il ya
plusieurs textes inscrits donc un texte
de cette importance celui de donner la
mort n'est pas un texte anodin il peut
pas passer en quelques heures
de façon bâclé devant le parlement
il nécessite une réflexion qui je pense
qu'ils et qui est importante qui est
pertinente
ça pose de vraies questions sur le fond
derrière il y a de la détresse des
familles il y à des choix il ya question
il est question de la relation à la mort
qui touchent chacun qui touche chaque
famille est souvent dans des situations
de détresse donc on ne peut pas passer
une loi aussi important qui serait une
rupture majeure dans notre droit en
quelques heures
donc si le gouvernement était sur le
semestre
concrètement à titre ressources en
croire un proche de jean leonetti center
est ce que vous êtes allé et ce au sein
des personnels pour l'euthanasie ou
est-ce qu'un parent ou trop vers
l'accompagnement de je pense que on ne
peut pas résumer
une question aussi importante dans un
choix dans un choix comme vous le
formuler
la loi leonetti a constitué une très
grande avancée 1 sur les directives
anticipées pour accompagner les malades
en fin de vie
ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui pour que cette
loi soit bien appliquée elle est
appliquée de de beaucoup de familles
elle est souhaitée en tout cas par
beaucoup de familles s'est multiplié les
soins palliatifs les services de soins
palliatifs il ya un déficit très
important à la matière donc avant
d'aller plus loin je pense qu'il
faudrait déjà faire en sorte que cette
loi qui est une bonne loi s'applique
partout et en tous lieux du territoire
et que dans tous les grands centres
hospitaliers au nez des services de
soins palliatifs il y en a un
remarquable à antibes dont chacun
malheureusement dans des circonstances
tragiques et je connais des amis qui ont
eu à malheureusement pour un des proches
à l'utiliser et très est très performant
après personnellement je ne tranche pas
cette question voilà moi je donné la
mort au nom de la société est une
rupture profonde
voilà quels sont les critères
on a vu ce cas il ya quelques années en
belgique où une jeune fille vous voulez
avoir recours à la tête à l'euthanasie
parce qu'elle avait une détresse
psychique
attention voilà attention où l'on met
les limites quand on commence à jouer
avec ces critères on peut tout se dire
qu'on aurait envie ou qu'il y à des
conditions il ya des moments qui peuvent
légitimer ce choix qui est un choix
individuel mais là on passe de
l'individuel au collectif
donc je suis extrêmement prudent et en
l'état je ne voterai pas ce texte demain
à l'assemblée nationale un mot sur le
sénat qui examine lui la loi séparatisme
la droite qui durcit le texte notamment
sur la question du voile on sait vous
avez été très critiques lors de l'examen
de ce texte à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que le texte qui va sortir du
sénat correspond aux textes que vous
souhaitez c'est un texte qui est
naturellement très très améliorée et je
salue la pertinence et le courage de mes
amis sénateurs de la majorité derrière
gérard larcher bruno retailleau qui ont
porté des mesures qui sont
indispensables et que le gouvernement
avait totalement occulté avec la
complicité de la majorité en marche à
l'assemblée nationale voilà
l'interdiction du port du voile dans les
sorties scolaires pour les accompagnants
scolaires est une mesure de bon sens de
courage je l' ai défendu à plusieurs
reprises sans succès à l'assemblée
nationale une fois ça a failli passer
avec le soutien de jean michel blanquer
mais la majorité en marche qui est très
animée par des approches quand même
favorable à une forme de communautarisme
s'y était opposé donc il y à des
avancées il y en a eu sur ces questions
de de port de signes religieux
ostentatoires et je salue le courage du
sénat je me battrai à l'assemblée
nationale pour que la majorité en marche
ne détricote pas le travail qui a été
fait pour tuner m'en parlent par le
sénat j'ai craint je crains que le la
majorité et le gouvernement ne revienne
au texte initial qui est un texte sans
ambition sans courage sans volonté
réelle de s'attaquer au communautarisme
islamistes qui n'est même pas cité qui
n'était même pas cité dans le texte du
gouvernement où il y avait une espèce
d'amalgamé où toutes les religions se
été mise
quelque part sur le même plan et où on
n'évoquait pas là dans la dangerosité de
l'islamisme on va parler de deux
dossiers locaux maintenant avant de
parler de la tempête alex avec patrice
un mot sur air france est la fermeture
de ses bases sains notamment à marseille
à nice pour les personnels navigants
vous y opposez vous avez écrit au
gouvernement
est ce que vous croyez que le
gouvernement ne réponde favorablement
avant demande au moment où bruno le
maire demande à air france de faire des
efforts le gouvernement a obtenu de la
part de l'union européenne de la
commission de pouvoir et d air france
c'est une bonne chose moi je suis
attaché à la force de notre compagnie
nationale
ça fait partie des symboles de la france
on a laissé partir beaucoup de nos
symboles on a laisser affaiblir beaucoup
d'éléments qui ont participé de notre
rayonnement et de notre souveraineté
nationale
on fragilise aujourd'hui la filière
nucléaire on a laissé détruire alstom
donc il faut sauver la france j'y suis
attaché et l'état français effectué un
effort de recapitalisation à plusieurs
milliards d'euros qui est conséquent
mais qui est indispensable mais il faut
qu'il y ait des contreparties et je le
dis au pdg d'air france monsieur ben
smits qui regarde d'un peu loin les
territoires français leur implantation
il y à la nécessité que la compagnie
nationale et bien en contrepartie de ces
aides de l'état donc du contribuable
français et bien prennent portant regard
équitable sur tous les territoires et la
vision lui demande de faire des efforts
pour l'entrepris la vie l effort de
compléter la ville n'est pas qu'à paris
une compagnie nationale elle ne peut pas
tourner simplement autour de l'aéroport
roissy charles de gaulle avec des
meubles qui concentre toutes les lignes
sur paris et qui oublie la province la
base de nice l essentiel nice c'est la
deuxième plateforme aéroportuaire
française c'est la destination
touristique après paris la plus
importante c'est un aéroport qui était
en pleine croissance c'est un outil
économique pour toute une région et il
faut continuer à le soutenir et c'est ce
que je demande au gouvernement dans le
cadre de l'aide apportée à air france un
mot sur la tempête alex patricia peu
près un milliard de dégâts aux lois sur
le terrain les remboursements tarder à
arriver que ce soit ceux de l'état ou de
l'assurance
c'est quoi le problème selon vous cette
somme est logé un autre complexe où
c'est une volonté de jouer la montre le
président de la république était venu
quelques jours après la tempête c'était
le 7 octobre dans les alpes-maritimes il
avait pris des engagements sur plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros le site
c'était sa phrase elle était prononcée 1
breil sur roya aujourd'hui sur ces plus
centaines de millions d'euros annoncé
par le président de la république alors
que nous avons globalement autour d'un
mis au moins un milliard d'euros de
dégâts publica sans compter ceux qui
relèvent des assurances pour le
patrimoine privé notamment où le
patrimoine assurables sur ces centaines
de millions d'euros annoncé par l'état
six mois plus tard nous avons commémoré
cette tragédie
la semaine dernière ça faisait six mois
toutes les collectivités n'ont reçu que
26 millions d'euros de la part de l'état
et pour le département des
alpes-maritimes présidée par charles
ange ginésy à peine 8 un peu plus de 8
millions d'euros alors que nous avons
déjà engagé pour la seule collectivité
départementale 75 millions d'euros de
dépenses donc le compte n'y est pas moi
j'ai confiance en la parole du président
de la république il a dit des choses je
pense qu'il aura à coeur de les
respecter mais là encore on parlait des
vaccins tout à l'heure on est victime
d'une forme de bureaucratie paralysante
voilà il y a aujourd'hui des arbitrages
budgétaires qui prive nos territoires
d'avoir ces fonds et d'avoir des
décisions rapides
tout est trop long dans notre pays tout
est paralysé tout est freiné par cette
technocratie cette bureaucratie qui nous
empêchent d'agir et d'agir très vite il
y a
lens il ya urgence pour reconstruire il
ya aussi urgence pour protéger les
populations parce qu'à l'automne le même
phénomène pourrait se reproduire
donc il y à des villages qui doivent
être protégés le département des
alpes-maritimes la métropole nice côte
d'azur présidée par christian estrosi
ont uni leurs forces
on est allé très vite dans la
reconstruction on a fait une task force
eh bien on a besoin aujourd'hui de cette
solidarité pour protéger aussi on a 90
millions d'euros de chantiers en
préparation pour ériger des digues de
protection mais on a besoin de l'aide de
erik satie dernière question de patrice
sur les régionales et la stratégie dans
votre région sud alors une vraie liste
de rassemblement qui réunit les derrière
derrière renaud muselier pardon les
républicains l'excentris les maquereaux
triste tout ça pour battre le front
national est ce que vous en rêvez ah non
je crois que ça serait le meilleur moyen
pour faire élire thierry mariani je
crois que la confusion n'est jamais
opportune en politique moi je suis pour
une ligne claire et pour une ligne
droite je les dis à renaud muselier je
crois qu'ils partagent mon point de vue
je préside la commission nationale
d'investitures elle se réunira dans
quelques minutes au siège des
républicains nous investirons ce matin
renaud muselier
je serai derrière lui dans cette
campagne à la tête de la fédération des
alpes-maritimes qui est la première
fédération de france mais je pense qu'il
faut je les ai toujours dit et vous me
connaissez c'est une ligne que j'ai
toujours tenu depuis 2010 est en marche
n'a pas fait du bien à notre pays en
marche a porté le déclassement de la
france en marche derrière emmanuel
macron a mal géré la crise sanitaire en
marche n'a pas répondu aux problèmes de
sécurité de l'immigration donc pourquoi
nous serions allié avec un parti que
nous combattons et dont nous dénonçons
aujourd'hui le bilan moi je
pour qu'on soit bien clair eric ciotti
christophe castaner il tend la main
renaud muselier pour vous il doit
refuser cette main tendue renaud
muselier c'est ce que vous nous dites
c'est pas une main tendue c'est un piège
grossier d'un parti à la déroute qui
cherchent une roue de secours pour se
sauver
soyons clairs sur nos idées nous n'avons
rien à voir avec en marche donc
combattons sur nos idées sur nos valeurs
sur le bon bilan de renaud muselier
nous n'avons pas besoin de confusion
parce que quand il ya de la confusion et
bien les électeurs ont une forme de
logique et je pense que toute forme
d'alliance conduira à l'élection de nos
adversaires dans la région et renaud
muselier vous a certifié qu'il ne
s'allierait pas avec la en marche
dès sa naissance est ce que nous lui
disons très clair vous à dire et je suis
convaincu oui c'est ce qu'il m'a dit je
suis convaincu que c'est ce qui se
forment sinon il aura pas l'investiture
des républicains il sera investi ce
matin parce que nous lui faisons
confiance
merci beaucoup merci avec ce tee d'avoir
été notre invité merci patrice maggio on
regarde la une de nice-matin astrazeneca
le mal aimé
c'est à la une de nice-matin aujourd'hui
merci messieurs
[Musique]